yeah getting you this one a little late
sorry about that i had to
help a friend move and then afterwards i
was like let me just
lay down for a couple hours just a
couple hours now
what happened so yeah a little tardy on
this one can't wait till i'm 95
so people can just stop asking me to
help them move
forever and i can stop having to say yes
anyhow let's talk about this movie
you've been
dying to hear me talk about
tom clancy's without remorse which when
i look at the title it looks like it's
saying tom clancy is without remorse
regardless without remorse stars michael
b jordan it's based off of a tom clancy
novel from the early 90s so you know
governments
agents soldiers spying espionage foreign
relations that might go bad
oh you know it's that movie though it
has the added effect of
being a revenge tale as well which
brings me
all right let's talk about what i like
michael b jordan i thought he was great
in the movie one could say and would be
correct in saying michael b
jordan totally made this movie not in
that johnny depp as captain jack sparrow
totally made pirates of the caribbean
the curse of the black pearl you know
were the movies still
fun but you know that one character and
that actor totally made it no no
michael b jordan's the good part of the
movie michael b
jordan does more for this movie than
this movie ever does for him
though there were a couple of effects in
terms of executions and style
i thought there was some stylistic
things in this movie i thought they
looked good whether it be someone
getting taken out a stealth takedown
explosion that felt impactful i thought
this movie did have
style example there's a scene where this
plane's going down in water it's in the
cabin they're all trying to get out and
the cabin's turning because it's going
down so the entire set
of the inside of the plane is turning i
thought that was cool which is my way of
saying is this movie is a cake
maybe the cake looked good but the cake
itself was just
generic i use a lot of cake
metaphors in my reviews
though we all know the cake is a lie if
you can't relate it to food it's just
not relatable the problem with this
movie is like you've seen it a hundred
times before maybe back in the early 90s
when the book was written
maybe it was groundbreaking which is
kind of unfair because just because it's
based off of a book
doesn't mean they followed the book i
don't know i haven't read the book but
how many times have we seen that it's
based off of a book it's like
that is supposed to be that book sure
so who knows man i heard the book is
good at least amazon reviews say it's
good but i'm not an early 90s tom clancy
thriller novel enthusiast i'm a 2021
moviegoer
and video gamer which is to say i've
seen everything in this movie
done before and done much better also
throughout video gamer because if you
want to see a story where these people
are soldiers and they feel like they're
tools of the government they very much
are that play metal gear solid i think
this has to be metal gear solid but you
know what i'm saying everything in this
movie we've seen before like right down
to the revenge thing how many revenge
movies have you seen
before where it's like oh family was
killed soldier has to go rogue
right and you see the plot coming to my
way okay this might be spoilerish
do you you don't care if you're gonna
watch this movie
you watched it before sunday so is this
what means you're not going to watch it
right so my point is when you cast guy
pierce in a movie like this where
there's clearly some douchebag behind
the scenes
maybe it's some trait or two don't cast
guy pierce
cause we just know why because the
casting is just too perfect you can't be
that perfect in your casting we've all
seen count of monte cristo
i haven't seen something this obvious
since brad dorf in
alien resurrection being the creep
scientist i guess we weren't supposed to
know he was a creep scientist but he was
brad douriff so
out the gate we were like yeah weirdo
so let's continue same thing with guy
pierce here maybe for somebody who
doesn't watch a lot of movies they're
just like i was
ordering potpourri on amazon prime and
here it is this movie was suggested to
me
because it is in fact on amazon prime
case you were wondering maybe they'll be
like wow
i haven't seen anything like that
because i haven't seen a movie since the
bush years then
bush jr bush senior for the rest of us i
feel like you're gonna come out of this
movie like okay so
it feels like it's borrowed from this
this this this and this which
all came out after the tom clancy novel
but since we're talking movies
that's where it matters it's gonna be
like this you're not gonna remember it
in t minus one day yep already forgot
all right so tom clancy's without
remorse have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's your
favorite thriller movie maybe it's a
revenge movie maybe it's a thriller
movie maybe it's a political espionage
movie
maybe it's a foreign relations political
political espionage movie what's your
favorite tom clancy story that doesn't
have to be a tom clancy's story whatever
it is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you